cremona
giusto t
una delle
più importanti al mondo per il
patrimonio musicale che possiede intanto
per la presenza la nascita di un
compositore come claudio monteverdi alla
fine del cinquecento che ha inventato
insieme ad altri maestri della musica
l'opera lirica quindi il genere di
spettacolo dal vivo più rappresentato al
mondo quindi abbiamo una storia che che
inizia secoli e secoli fa meno e
monteverdi e stato uno veramente dai più
grandi della della storia della musica
[Musica]
l'altra figura ovviamente legata alla
liuteria quindi stradivari ma non
soltanto stradivari una serie di
personaggi e di liutai che hanno operato
a cremona amati guarneri del gesù e poi
l'ultimo compositore che cremona visto
nascere amilcare ponchielli nella nel
suo territorio nella sua provincia
e vero che cremona è un po la città
della musica per svariate ragioni questa
cosa a cremona l'ho sempre respirata
molto è una città che quando propone
propone sempre con una intenzione
comunque culturale non è una città che
propone solo tanto per ri per la ri
creatività tra virgolette c'è anche un
concerto non è quasi mai fine a se
stesso
questo desiderio di riportare la musica
come appunto come se fosse il gioiello
della città
oggettivamente ce n'è un po per tutti i
gusti
[Musica]
se andiamo a vedere un po il panorama
degli spettacoli di sicuro la parte del
leone l'ha fatta il festival monteverdi
a un po ripreso gli stilemi antichi
infatti è un festival che ha un taglio
ben specifico
[Musica]
il fatto di legare cremona per esempio
repertorio antico e barocco la proietta
normalmente naturalmente verso un
repertorio contemporaneo e jazz
vuoi per strumenti vuoi per modalità
esecutive
[Musica]
dall 87 ho visto diversi festival a
cremona andando ancora più indietro si
parla del recitar cantando i festival
più rock cremonesi tipo il motorock lì
ero veramente piccolo i festival di
porta musa noi siamo passati in mezzo ai
porte aperte festival
[Musica]
negli ultimi anni il lupo nel rock
stiamo forse vivendo tra tutte le epoche
che stiamo un po immaginando d'epoca un
po più vivace sia dal punto di vista
della risposta del pubblico che dal
punto di vista del popolo stessa che
viene messa in campo sono molto contento
che in questi anni siano nate nuove
realtà come il tanta roba festival che
credo sia il proseguimento naturale di
sostanza di un cambio generazionale è un
festival che ormai è notoriamente un
festival di riferimento e penso che
arrivi gente da tutta italia
tanta roba si fa da di quattro giorni
con 40mila presenze su una città di
70.000 va da sé che
non sono tutti da chiave mora
[Applauso]
[Musica]
da musicista di consigliere
assolutamente la città di cremona ma
perché sono diversi eventi diverse
possibilità di vario livello varie
categorie e questo ha permesso appunto
che anche dal punto di vista delle
realtà che si occupano di tecniche
fonica audio se fosse diciamo un certo
implemento da quel punto di vista a
livello proprio qualitativo stiamo
parlando di livello qualitativo e
ovviamente anche umano ho incontrato
persone che negli anni hanno dimostrato
molto interesse e che si sono avvicinati
al nostro lavoro che è una fetta molto
grande e più di costruire un evento ma
che in realtà comprende tanti livelli di
attenzione e di partecipazione a questa
cosa permette innanzitutto di affrontare
le produzioni in maniera più serena e
con già diciamo un team molto rodato ed
efficace dalla beretta quando arrivi per
capirci alla spia che suona veramente
bene sono tutte cose che sembrano
semplici però se messe tutte insieme
oggettivamente fanno bello l'evento
hanno spesso dimostrato nel tempo di
essere tecnici e fuoriclasse gente
veramente brava gente che ci ha messo il
cuore
continua a sostenere che è che loro ci
sono ancora adesso delle figure tecniche
di primissimo livello
cremona è dunque il luogo dove esperire
musica frequentare le istituzioni
culturali come il teatro il museo e le
sale da concerti ma è anche il luogo
dove formarsi
io effettivamente senza cremona non
sarei diventato quello che sono e penso
che la funzione sia proprio questa i
dati gli strumenti terreno fertile per
poi sviluppare un prodotto il corso ci
sono tante opportunità una ventina
d'anni fa è nato il conservatorio o
meglio istituto pareggiato musicale sono
stata presa nel 2016 all'accademia
walter stauffer di cremona con salvatore
accardo
diciamo che è stata una grandissima
sorpresa perché ci tenevo veramente
tantissimo
[Musica]
la facoltà di musicologia con un taglio
molto legato allo studio dei codici alla
paleografia musicale così a una storia
ed ha proprio una sede specifica si
tratta di per chi non lo sapesse di un
dipartimento universitario tra le
eccellenze a livello internazionale per
quanto riguarda gli studi musicologici
cioè una quantità di persone che
arrivano veramente da tutto il mondo qui
[Musica]
tante persone si sono fermate a cremona
e poi hanno proseguito il loro cammino
anche di ricerca e di approfondimento
nell'ambito della città è normale vedere
vedere ragazze in giro per cremona con
custodio sulle spalle che di qualsiasi
nazionalità proprio qualsiasi tantissima
gente così arriva ogni tanto li becco
perché io sono in piazza della pace
quindi proprio al centro di cremona tra
museo e duomo è detto tantissimi passare
ecco quello sì anche dall'hashtag prima
est e così li vedo passare nella nebbia
volte più gente aveva il pci si
contamina da qualsiasi non solo a
livello italiano ma in generale è più il
contesto il tessuto diventa interessante
creiamo una musica come si chiama ormai
a mondomusica ha cambiato a cremona
musica è una fiera importantissima
perché non arrivano solo aiuta i non
solo musicisti non solo commercianti di
legname corte di tutti i colori ma un po
tutti partecipano anche i cremonesi
stessi perché si suona per strada
eccetera e tutte queste connessioni che
poi si creano all'interno fanno sì che
diventi uno degli elementi di una
proposta più ampia
[Musica]
io credo che una realtà culturale come
cerchio arcipelago o situazioni simili
abbiano anche come scopo quello non solo
di offrire diciamo così dei servizi ma
anche di produrre cultura il modo di
porsi come un luogo aperto soprattutto
non solo dove consumare e suonare
veramente o imparare uno strumento ma il
luogo dove prendere una chitarra una
batteria un microfono e provare a
costruire a sperimentare il linguaggio
musicale insieme
l'idea è sempre stata quella di creare
una scuola che fosse non solo una scuola
o un conservatorio ma un luogo di
condivisione della musica la città della
canzone nasce come costola di tutta una
serie di persone che escono
dall'università e dal dipartimento di
musicologia quel progetto sia basato per
anni su un unico grosso evento annuale
che durava una settimana un laboratorio
appunto destinato a giovani cantautori
che da tutta italia venivano qua cremona
per lavorare con delle guide
cantautori musicisti affermati a livello
anche internazionale in certi casi per
scrivere lavorare sulla scrittura di
proprie e bozze creative che cosa e
città della musica non è solo circuitare
organizzare ma è produrre stradivari
violini faceva non è che li comprava li
vendeva back to school nasce proprio su
questo si cercava di come dire
stimolarli sul fatto di credere anche
nel proprio capitale creativo ed
espressivo nel giro di pochi anni hanno
iniziato intervenire come ospiti
figure rilevanti della scena nazionale
da manuel agnelli che stanno anche
cristiano godano e vale con francesco
bianconi baustelle zampaglione per me ha
fatto franzi cioccio insomma tanti bel
carnet di artisti molto e molto di value
elio per le celebrazioni monteverdiani
quindi orchestra più e le cose
bellissime
ti ha creato una rete di collaborazione
per questa posta live che poi vedeva una
scaletta molto interessante che
miscelava il repertorio delle storie
tese con delle opere di claudio
monteverdi c'è una quantità esorbitante
di botteghe di juta i tantissimi
musicisti da tutto il mondo arrivano per
diciamo per trovare il proprio strumento
per cercare il proprio suono cremona è
rinata negli anni
nel novecento appunto con la scuola
perché è sembrato riportare una
tradizione
io dico sempre ho imparato il mestiere
come come nel settecento c'è proprio
tutto a mano tagliare fu proprio sì alla
vecchia facendo le ricerche su come
lavorava antonio stradivari che radice
colo cento degli amati è abbastanza
documentabile e soprattutto i grandi
liutai si sono affermati su quello cioè
su questo metodo che è stato usato da
dai maestri italiani ogni bottega vende
i propri strumenti e ai propri strumenti
e della diffidenza e veramente una
particolarità all'anno faccio circa 67
violini a volte mi capita di fare un
violoncello
però siccome suono anche il violino è
per me il suono che capisco di più forse
diciamo che mi viene più facile insieme
alla mia collega sibille sua meno un
gruppo così che siamo tra l'altro 3
liutai e che suonano i loro strumenti
o no
sono strumenti che sono estremamente
sensibili e subiscono variazioni quasi
tutti i giorni anche per la temperatura
e diciamo gli spostamenti sono come
degli esseri umani in un certo senso
quindi vanno trattati molto molto bene
[Musica]
il teatro ponchielli ha un'acustica
straordinario
però diciamo che è proprio l'acustica da
teatro quindi magari può essere più
adatta all'ambito operistico e sinfonico
mentre l'auditorium giovanni arvedi del
museo del violino ha un'acustica che è
stata diciamo progettata apposta per gli
strumenti ad arco
io lo ritengo veramente azzeccato questo
auditorium musicista sta al centro e
tutto rotondo perciò il suono gira bene
lo trovo veramente fantastica un
ambiente estremamente avvolgente e è
molto bello io sono molto orgoglioso
nel mio piccolo di aver creato
una realtà nonostante fosse uno studio
molto piccolo perché erano 22 stanze 4
metri per 4 molto belle però sono nate
collaborazioni molto importanti li
dentro ho prodotto cose per laura
pausini per elisa per renga per un sacco
di gente
abbiamo avuto l'opportunità di cantare
davanti a giovanni paolo ii in castel
gandolfo a pochi metri di distanza dal
papa il quale ha scrutato negli occhi
ciascuno di noi ed è stato un momento
estremamente emozionante mi emoziono
ancora adesso solo a parlarne noi gli
abbiamo proposto un programma tutto
dedicato a maria prima data dell'ultimo
tour fatto come la chitarra di gianluca
grignani al teatro ponchielli
sono andato a fare una data di un tour a
piedi sono uscito di casa col trolley
col pass o attraverso piazza duomo
suonato con kelly
fate il concerto trolley sono tornato a
casa nel mio letto a dormire
c'è un detto wow sto andando al
ponchielli cioè il ponchielli ci ho
visto il mio primo concerto che ronnie
pu pensate nel 95 del mondo del pop il
ponchielli per me è il mio forum
d'assago c'è poco da fare d'altro
meraviglioso il fatto di poterci andare
a piedi da solo per andare a fare quello
che mi è sempre piaciuto fare nella vita
è stata una cosa impagabile un diamante
si compone di molte sfaccettature ogni
sfaccettatura che sia musica
contemporanea musica antica musica
ottocentesca ovviamente ha una luce
propria tutte queste luci che provengono
dalle varie sfaccettature del diamante
compongono una luce unica che è il
patrimonio musicale di cremona
devo salutare no ho già salutato
benissimo venisse noi
vado io bevo un goccio d'acqua e perché
sennò ogni due secondi ti faccia allegri
inter visto prima tipo scheda
un'intervista borsa prima al mio ego le
mani o li tolgo o signore so chi sia
le campane anche per questo senso di
pace che mi dava la città e di
esatto andavamo a vedere il treno trino
e non possono altro treno
e poi vabbè tanto avanti nel tempo
sono arrivate
ho fatto i treni aspettiamo non può
veramente belle ci siamo
[Risate]
ho detto un sacco di cose scusa ti
aspetta non dirò mai le cose come vedete
prima perché non mi ricordo cosa ho
detto aspetta che sono in vuoti di
memoria
effervescente diciamo sì sì quello razza
poco solo borroi con l'avete capito
noche nastro abbastanza riassunto prof
va bene
[Musica]